[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ihn allen einen schönen
guten Abend katja ist wieder mit mir im
Studio hat später die sportlichen
Höhepunkte ja schönen guten Abend dann
blicken wir jetzt gemeinsam auf unsere
Themen Start mit einem Signal bei der
Weltklimakonferenz sagen mehrere Staaten
Geld für einen Fond zu der ärmeren
Ländern bei Klimaschäden helfen soll
wie geht's weiter mit der
nahostfeuerpause die Hamas bekennt sich
zu einem Anschlag in Jerusalem mit
mehreren Toten und ruft zur Eskalation
auf Abschied von einer diplomatenlegende
die nicht unumstritten war die Welt
trauert um den früheren US Außenminister
Henry
[Musik]
Kissinger 203 wird das wohl heißeste
Jahr seit Beginn der Industrialisierung
sein sagen die vereinten Nationen zum
Auftakt der Weltklimakonferenz der Ton
ist gesetzt und immerhin schon an Tag 1
gibt's mit der Einrichtung eines
Entschädigungsfonds auch schon ein
Ergebnis aber im Großen und Ganzen
hinken große Industriestaaten auch
dieses Jahr ihren klimaversprechen
hinterher Gastgeber der Konferenz sind
die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate nach
Dubai kommen rund 70.000 Teilnehmer aus
fast 200 Ländern das größte Problem also
das Klimaschutz Ziel von Paris die
globale Erwärmung auf höchstens 1,5° zu
begrenzen ist nicht zu schaffen
feststeht reichere sollen an ärmere
Länder Zahlen die von Stürmen dürren
Fluten oder steigendem Meeresspiegel
betroffen sind Deutschland sagt etwa 91
Millionen Euro zu Elisa
miiebach der Hammer fällt in Dubai in
neue Hände das Emirat reich geworden mit
Öl übernimmt die Präsidentschaft der un-
Klimakonferenz und muss jetzt liefern
vdert un Generalsekretär Antonio
Guterres wir erleben den Klimakollaps in
Echtzeit und die Folgen sind
verheerend immerhin gerade zu diesen
Folgen fällt schon eine Entscheidung der
auf der vergangenen Klimakonferenz
beschlossene Fond wird
gefüllt reiche Staaten die den
Klimawandel verursacht haben geben Geld
an ärmere Länder wenn diese von den
Klimafolgen getroffen werden eine
Überraschung der Fond startet mit einer
Allianz der Emirate und Deutschland die
jeweils 100 Millionen Dollar versprechen
weitere Staaten folgen mit kleineren
Beiträgen wir haben heute Geschichte
geschrieben denn zum ersten Mal wurde
eine Entscheidung am ersten Tag einer
Klimakonferenz
angenommen eine Neuigkeit auch deshalb
weil sich Länder wie die Golfstaaten
bisher weigerten in den Fond einzuzahlen
Betroffene aus den Ländern die den
Klimawandel besonders spüren sagen die
Ankündigungen heute können nur ein
erster Schritt sein
im Pazifik kostet die Umsiedlung eines
Dorfes das von der Klimakrise betroffen
ist rund 100 Millionen Dollar und das
ist nur ein Dorf auf einer Insel im
Pazifik und ein von kann nur die Schäden
mindern verhindern kann diese nur ein
Ausstieg aus den fossilen Energien ob
dieser von vielen langersehnte
Meilenstein ausgerechnet im Ölland Dubai
beschlossen werden kann wird erst der
Abschluss in zwei Wochen
zeigen
Andreas Stamm ist für uns in Dubai dabei
Andreas finanzielle Hilfen sind das eine
das große 1,5° Ziel aber ist ja laut
Experten nicht mehr zu erreichen was
denn aber
dann ja dann stünde die Weltgemeinschaft
wirklich vor einem Scherbenhaufen denn
das ist das höchste Ziel und vielleicht
heißt es irgendwann mal in den
Geschichtsbüchern dass man in Dubai die
letzte Chance vertan hat denn es haben
noch nicht alle Staaten aufgegeben und
die fordern was die Wissenschaft eben
mahnt an MT wir müssen so schnell wie
möglich Aussteigen aus der Verbrennung
fossiler Energieträger Weg mit Kohle Öl
Gas sonst wird das nichts mit dem 1,5°
Ziel also die Erwärmung die globale
Erwärmung eben auf diesen Bereich zu ja
begrenzen ähm das sieht wirklich nicht
gut aus denn vor allen die Erdöl
förördernden Staaten aber nicht nur die
auch Schwergewichte wie China und Indien
die sagen das SE zu früh es sei
unrealistisch aber ähm das wird man in
zwei Wochen sehen ob das klappt es
braucht glaube ich ein kleines Wunder
von Dubai aber selbst dann
Trippelschritte zählen denn erstens
jedes Zehntelgrad mehr heißt
gravierendere Folgen und zweitens selbst
die Kritiker der Kop müssen ja und sagen
es auch offen sagen und erklären diese
Veranstaltung dieses Forum ist noch
immer das Beste um die Weltgemeinschaft
zusammenzubringen und um gemeinsam im
Kampf gegen die Klimakrise voranzukommen
vielen Dank nach Dubai Andreas
Stamm ja man kann es drehen und wenden
wie man will auch auch Deutschland hält
Zusagen nicht ein dafür ist die Ampel
jetzt juristisch zu mehr Klimaschutz
verdonnert worden Christiane
hübscher vor allem sie beide sind
gemeint bundesbauministerin Geiwitz und
Verkehrsminister Wissing in ihren beiden
Bereichen werden die Klimaziele seit
Jahren nicht erreicht das
Oberverwaltungsgericht
Berlin-Brandenburg verurteilt beide
Ministerien nun dazu Sofortmaßnahmen
einzuleiten die Kläger aus der
Umweltbewegung sind mit dem
Richterspruch hoch zufrieden es ist ein
sehr guter Tag für den Klimaschutzes
Gericht hat uns in allen Punkten Recht
gegeben und zwingt jetzt diese
Bundesregierung die völlig fehlgeleitete
Klimapolitik zu korrigieren und
entsprechend sofortprogramme für die
Sektoren Verkehr und Gebäude vorzulegen
gaiwitz und Wissing Teilen heute nur
schriftlich mit man wolle sich das
Urteil genau anschauen der
Verkehrsminister will vor allem prüfen
lassen ob Revision zum
Bundesverwaltungsgericht eingelegt wird
der Druck auf Wissing aber dürfte
steigen Steuervorteile für Diesel
abschaffen oder od das berühmte
Tempolimit das sind und bleiben die
Vorschläge des grünen Koalitionspartners
wir haben gleich konkret das
Verkehrsministerium adressiert und
gesagt wir haben ja Gesprächsbedarf aber
auch Gesprächsbereitschaft es geht jetzt
darum die kurzfristig wirkende Maßnahmen
zu identifizieren und eben in Geltung zu
bringen das Gerichtsurteil will ja nicht
warten sondern will umgesetzt werden
dieses Urteil zwingt die Bundesregierung
wirksame klimaschutzsofortprogramme
aufzustellen denn klar ist Autos Gebäude
haben mehr klimaschädliches Gas
ausgestoßen als gesetzlich erlaubt und
hier muss die Bundesregierung das hat
das Gericht heute deutlich gemacht
direkt gegensteuern ein wegweisendes
Urteil auch wenn das letzte Wort das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht haben dürfte
geht die Bundesregierung tatsächlich in
Revision gewinnt sie Zeit Zeit in der
sie ihr neues Klimaschutzprogramm
verabschieden könnte dann liefen die
Klagen ins
lehere zum Krieg in nah Ost sieben Tage
lang schwiegen die Waffen weitgehend die
Feuerpause wurde noch mal bis morgen
früh verlängert aber heute erschüttert
ein Anschlag Israel in Jerusalem
erschießen Palästinenser Zivilisten die
Hamas bekennt sich dazu ja sie setzt
offenbar auf neue Gewalt keine guten
Vorzeichen auch wenn die
Terrororganisation heute erneut Geiseln
freiließ luten
leinos die Feuerpause gerade erst
verlängert erreicht der Terror der Hamas
wieder Israel an einer Bushaltestelle in
Jerusalem zwei palästinensische
Attentäter eröffnen das Feuer töten drei
Menschen die ham reklamiert die Bluttat
für sich und ruft auf zu einer
Eskalation des Widerstands fast
zeitgleich landet US Außenminister
blinken in Israel trotz des Anschlags
setzt er sich ein für eine Fortsetzung
der
Feuerpause wir haben den letzten Tagen
eine sehr positive Entwicklung gesehen
Geiseln die nach Hause kommen dieser
Prozess ist wichtig er produziert
Ergebnisse und wir hoffen dass er
weitergehen
kann geiselabkommen und Feuerpause
scheinen auf der Kippe zu stehen beinah
wären sie die letzten Geiseln gewesen
die so freiommen 12 Israelis die
vergangene Nacht dem Roten Kreuz
übergeben wurden darunter drei
deutsch-israelische Doppelstaatler die
vergleichsweise einfachen Tage des
Austausches sind offenbar vorbei ein
Streit über die geiselliste für heute
konnte erst in letzter Minute beigelegt
werden wenn Hamas aufhört Geisel
freizulassen endet die Feuerpause und
wir nehmen den Kampf gegen sie wieder
auf h die Schwierigkeit inzwischen ist
der größte Teil der Frauen und Kinder
unter den Geiseln frei über die
weiterhin Gefangenen Männer und
Armeeangehörigen muss gewissermaßen neu
verhandelt werden für sie dürfte die
Hamas deutlich mehr freigelassene
palästinensische Häftlinge verlangen die
beiden ersten Geiseln der heutigen
Vereinbarung wurden am Nachmittag in
Gaza Stadt übergeben in den nächsten
Stunden sollen weitere Freilassungen
folgen wir gehen live nach telaviv zu
Michael extrem schwierige Phase aktuell
Feuerpause nur um einen Tag verlängert
dann noch der Anschlag heute in
Jerusalem wie kann es jetzt
weitergehen ganz genaus so nämlich nur
noch von Tag zu Tag israel will offenbar
den Druck auf die Hamas erhöhen dass
immer schwieriger wird sich auf neue
Namen auf dieser geiselaustauschliste zu
einigen und die Drohung mit der Sekunde
wo die letzte Waffenpause endet den
Kampf wieder aufzunehmen würde ich jetzt
nicht nur als leere kriegsretorik
einschätzen zugleich versucht die Hamas
den Kampf aus Gaza ins Westjordanland zu
tragen das ist die klare Botschaft
dieses Terroranschlags von heute die
auch noch mal schriftlich bekräftigt
worden ist das bitte sich auch dort die
Palästinenser erheben sollen das hat in
der Vergangenheit auch schon öfter
Versuche gegeben das zu probieren die
waren nicht erfolgreich auch deswegen
nicht weil Israel etwa 2000 Verdächtige
darunter 1000 100 mutmaßliche
hamasanhänger quasi proaktiv
festgenommen hat aber wenn die Kämpfe in
Gasa wieder auflacken dann könnte auch
der Plan der heramas für einen Aufstand
im Westjordanland aufgehen Michael
vielen Dank nach Tel
Aviv die Gräben sind tiefer geworden auf
der Welt und das zeigt sich auch bei der
OSZE der Organisation für Sicherheit und
Zusammenarbeit in Europa über die
Jahrzehnte hatte es in der OSZ e in der
auch die USA und Russland vertreten sind
bei Konflikten immer wieder
Gesprächskanäle gegeben aber
mittlerweile da krieselt es gewaltig
beim Außenministertreffen in
nordmazedonien stellt Russland die
Organisation in Frage Andreas
Küst Außenminister in scopje auf dem
roten Teppich zu sehen als sei nichts
gewesen sagen fast alle anderen
Außenminister aber Russland ist Mitglied
der OSZE und die kann nur einstimmig
entscheiden
wann Russland den Krieg beendet die
Frage überhört lavrov wie fast alle
Fragen und Vorwürfe heute Russland
blockiert die OSZE mit seinem Veto
blockiert den Haushalt blockiert den
Vorsitz zahlt seine Beiträge
nicht das perfidespiel der russischen
Regierung ist und war es eben auch
Organisationen die auf ein friedliches
Miteinander auf Kooperation setzen mit
dem brutalen angriffsk enegen die
Ukraine ebenfalls zu zerstören und das
lassen wir nicht zu dass es die OSZE
noch gibt liegt an Spenden die nicht nur
Deutschland sondern auch Nichtmitglieder
wie Japan geleistet haben lavrov dagegen
sieht Russland als Opfer dass der Westen
ausrotten
wolle die usze wird zu einem Anhängsel
von NATO und EU gemacht die Organisation
steht am Rande des Abgrunds und es
stellt sich die Frage ob es noch
sinnvoll ist
um sie
wierben hat sofort in der Sekunde nach
seiner Rede den Sitzungssaal wieder
verlassen er hat kaum einen der Appelle
kaum einen der Vorschläge kaum einen der
Vorwürfe persönlich gehört Russland
blockiert nicht nur die Zukunft der OSZE
es konterkariert auch ihren Sinn
normalerweise hätte Estland zum
Jahreswechsel den OSZE Vorsitz
übernommen wegen des Vetos von Russland
soll nun das neutrale Malta
übernehmen
die Konjunktur in Deutschland läuft
weiter mau das zeigt sich auch am
Arbeitsmarkt
266000 Menschen waren im November ohne
Job das sind nur 1000 weniger als im
Oktober normalerweise fällt der Rückgang
um diese Jahreszeit deutlicher aus die
Quote liegt bei
5,6% und auch der Vergleich mit dem
Vorjahresmonat ist enttäuschend da ist
die Zahl der Arbeitslosen um 172 000
gestiegen das Stuttgarter
Oberlandesgericht hat den Gründer einer
rechtsextremen Terrorgruppe zu 6 Jahren
Gefängnis verurteilt neben Werner s
bekamen auch neun weitere Angeklagte
Haftstrafen die Gruppe wollte nach
Überzeugung des Gerichts Anschläge auf
Moscheen verüben und so einen
Bürgerkrieg auslösen man habe verabredet
dafür Waffen und Geld zu
sammeln Frankreichs Präsident macron
nennt Henry Kissinger einen Giganten der
Geschichte Kanzler Scholz sagt die Welt
verliere einen besonderen Diplomaten der
frühere usaußenminister ist im Alter von
100 Jahren gestorben mit 15 war der
gebürtige Deutsche vor den Nazis
geflohen international vertrat er das
Amerika unter Präsidenten Nixen
erfolgreich aber oft auch in einer Art
die viele skrupellos nannten dennoch
Entspannung lag ihm bis zuletzt am
Herzen das Verhältnis zu China etwa über
ein langes diplomatenleben Elma Ten
geboren wird Heinrich Alfred Kissinger
entführt
1938 flieht seine jüdische Familie vor
den Nazis se Jahre später kehrt er als
US-Soldat zurück ist beteiligt am
wieraufbau der Zivilverwaltung ein
Brückenbauer später wird der Ehrenbürger
der Stadt fürührt uns die beiden Völker
sind vom bitteren Konflikt zum Frieden
und vom Frieden zur Versöhnung und zu
gemeinsamen Streben geschritten
Präsident Nixon holt den Historiker und
Politikwissenschaftler ins Zentrum der
Macht Kissinger mischt brilante Analyse
mit gnadenlosem Pragmatismus ein
Realpolitiker der alle Ideologien
verachtet unter seinem Einfluss beginnen
die Supermächte im Kalten Krieg mit der
Entspannungspolitik auch die deutsche
Ostpolitik liegt ganz auf seiner
Linie Schrift besiegelt das Ende des
Vietnamkriegs Jahre später als es
möglich gewesen wäre sagen Kritiker
Jahre mit 100000enden toten trotzdem
bekommt Kissinger den Friedensnobelpreis
auch dafür warnt er mit seiner
Geheimdiplomatie den Weg Richard Nixons
historischer Besuch bei maedong
Tauwetter in den Beziehungen zwischen
China und den
USA Henry Kissinger treuer Fan des
Fußballclubs führt bedeutender Europäer
und
Amerikaner auch umstritten ja aber vor
allem eines ein legendärer
[Musik]
Diplomat ja und mehr zu Henry Kissinger
in unserer Mediathek dort zu finden die
ZDF Doku der gnadenlose Pragmatiker bei
uns geht's jetzt sportlich weiter und
mit dir Katja und mit Biathlon und der
Staffel der Männer in östers und
Schweden und genau wie die Frauen
gestern landeten auch die deutschen
Männer auf Rang 3 es wäre allerdings
mehr drin gewesen die Schlüsselszene in
diesem Rennen das letzte schießen
schlloßläufer Johannes kühn für den
erkrankten Roman re in die Staffel
gerückt gleich auf mit dem
Drittplatzierten Franzosen F Kühen mit
Problemen kämpft gegen die Strafrunde
und muss dann 150 m extra laufen s
Schlussläufer ist wie gesagt jetzt nicht
mal Paradedisziplin habe ich glaube ich
zweimal gemacht bisher immer wenn jemand
kerngesund hingegen die norwegische
Staffel Norwegen gewinnt klar vor
Frankreich die deutschen bekommen
ebenfalls Blumen Platz
3 ich glaube wir haben schon besser
gespielt sagte zutreffend bayerntiner
Thomas Tuchel nach dem 00 in der Fußball
Champions League Entschuldigung gegen
den FC Kopenhagen auch nicht wirklich
gut gespielt hat Union Berlin bei
Sporting Braga dabei sah es zunächst
ganz passabel aus Robin gosens 1:0 42
minute dann dann aber wurde es Zea Rager
glich schließlich aus zum ein: ein
Endstand morgen abend könnte er Platzen
der Traum von Olympia für die deutschen
Fußballerinnen und Interimstrainer Horst
rubesch das Team muss morgen in Rostock
im vorletzten Gruppenspiel der nations
League gegen Dänemark gewinnen deutlich
dann darf weiter geträumt werden ein
besonderes Vertrauensverhältnis zwischen
Trainer und Mannschaft das scheint das
Erfolgsrezept bei den DFB Frauen zu sein
Inter Trainer Horst rubesch weiß um die
besondere Drucksituation vor dem Spiel
gegen Dänemark und findet die richtigen
Worte um der Mannschaft Mut zu machen es
muss einfach Spaß machen solche Spiele
zu spielen und die Erfahrung haben sie
und die Qualität dafür haben sie auch
dabei sind die däninen ein anderes
Kaliber als zuletzt die Isländerinnen da
gewann Deutschland zwar mit 2:0
überzeugend war der Auftritt trotzdem
nicht einen Sieg mit zweitoren Differenz
braucht es aber auch jetzt um die
realistische olympiachance zu erhalten
dann würde auch Horst RUB als Trainer
weitermachen das allein sollte schon
Motivation genug sein das Spiel morgen
8: hier im CDF vielen Dank Katja und wir
haben noch zum Schluss ein wunderschönes
Lied für
[Musik]
sie fairy tale of New York geschrieben
von Shane mcgen der jetzt 65-jährig
gestorben ist bei den Briten ist
fairytale 1 der Weihnachtslieder
schlecht hin aber irgendwie auch ein
Missverständnis denn eigentlich mixte
der Poet mcgen mit seiner Band The Pokes
irischen fol mit Punk aber manchmal eben
auch mit
[Musik]
Wehmut ja so viel vorweg zum Wetter
Glatteisgefahr im Süden ausfülich dann
gleich dazu Katja horneffer um 21:45 uh
das heute journal mit sias das war's von
uns morgen für Sie hier Barbara hallweg
danke und auf
[Musik]
bald guten Abend bis Samstagabend ziehen
gleich zwei Tiefs nämlich Robin 1 und
Robin 2 von den Pyrenäen über
Südfrankreich und die Alpen weiter nach
Osten in den Zentralalpen können bis
Samstagabend 50 bis 100 cm schneefallen
bei uns in Deutschland wird's besonders
gefährlich am Alpenrand da fällt nämlich
nicht nur Schnee oder Regen sondern auch
gefährlicher Glatteisregen weiter
Richtung Norden kommt Schnee aus den
Wolken heraus in Norddeutschland ist es
zum Teil auch mal trocken es Belitz sich
Nebel es gibt einige Schneeschauer an
der Ostsee und über den Schneeflächen im
Nordosten wird es sehr kalt da sinken
die Temperaturen zum Teil unter -10° +
3° sind es am oberrein und morgen liegen
die Temperaturen um den Gefrierpunkt am
oberrein werden 5° erreicht und doch
morgen vor allen Dingen am Vormittag
sollten Sie sich noch auf straßenglätter
einstellen im Süden von
badenwürttenemberg und Bayern sonst wird
das zum Teil ein ganz freundlicher Tag
mit einigen Schneeschauern an der Küste
und einem Wind aus nördlichen Richtungen
am Samstag verlassen uns die
Schneewolken ostwärts am Sonntag strahlt
dann die Sonne über den neuschneeflächen
besonders in den südlichen
Mittelgebirgen und es bleibt bei uns
kalt guten Abend